TURNING TO OUR NATIONAL LEAD
W,KING AT BEFORE
AND AFTEPHOTOS OATY
FLORIDA.
CLATH TO IS GROWING,
DAF A TER.
128 PEOPLE ARE S
THOU
LET'S GO NOWO CNN'S NICKVALEY
.
ATE KNOW
ABOUT THAT 7-YEAR-OLGIRL?
orter: WF IT HASN'T E CLEAR GHM
ST HOW PERSONAL OFIS HASR THE S,
STORY  THERSCORES THAT 7-YEAR-OO
BYAND THAT THA NOT JUST RE
ENOUGH, BUT HER FATH WAS THERE
DTIME OF THIS DISCOVERY.
S DISCOVERY WAS UNIQUELYPAINFULO
>> EVERY VICTIM WEDIFFICUL NIGH
ALYST IT STILL TAKES TE
HAS BET DIFFICUL
FOR EVERYONED T
>> JUS EXCRUCIATINEXPERIENCE AL.
INVESTIGATN HEH.RN NOW T
BUILDING
CNN'S DREW GRIFFIN I W DETAILOUI
WAS EXTENSIVE DAMAGE TE  BAC
>> T
DESPERATAR
CONTINUES EVEN AS THER
QUESTIONS OVER WHETHER THE REST
OF THE TOWER NEEDS TO COME>> THA
DEFINITELY HASEE
THZA
OUR MEN AND WOMEN THAT ARE
>> THE BUILDING WILL HE
IT'S JUST TOO A RISK.
FIRMOREAMTHAN A
VEREORIDA COND
BUILDING, POINTINGEAR THE POOL .
THE LETTER FROINROVIDES A
RS. FULL
SELY CAFFECT THE STABILITY OF TH
REJANTE
TRIT'S J EVIDENC
E NOT YET D,LEIRS, REPAIRS D
WLD
REQUIREDHENSIDE OL, H,O
THE , WAS TO REMAIN IN FOR THE
CONSULNT
DERESPONSE. TELLINGDID ITS N TOA
SAYING, ANSWERS WILLTI
UUS
NOWI A COME N NCED THEOWER'S
FORENSIC DEEP DIVE TO CALM
ARS.
>> AND GET TO THINT WHERE WE
CANITIVELY TELL THE PEOPAT ARETR
NOT WE THINK T'SSUCH H WILGI
S A LITTLEORE ACE OF MIND.orterG
DETERIORATIO IN DISPE.
HOOWPRT , THE CONCRETE
DETERIIO ACCELERATING,E RV D
GAGE GN RSE SI
INITIAN 2018.
HOMEOWNERS WERE IN THE D MORE T
MILLION FOR WORK WHEN THE
BUILDING FELL.
>> ANDAT 202LE
ALSO STATES THAT THEFIRM FOUND
SB,T BERESULTS WHENCOAMES
SOUST AD
THESE FAMILIES AREIN
AND NONS
>> THEY DESERVTHE ANSWERS.
THANKS SO MUCH, IN.
LET'S DISCUSS L OFD AUTHOR OF "W
STRUCTURESAIHE WLSA PRINCI
CONSULTANT AFTER FOR JNG
YOU JUST
THEPORTS OF WATER DAMAGE
AND CRACKS IN  D
GIVEN EVERYTHING W S
LEARN, WHAT DO YOU THINK CAUSEG?
UNTIL THE ENNEERS HA  FOWHIL
CHO EXAMINE ALTHE DEBRIS
AND TO GO H
OF HOW
DESIGNED.
BUE INDICATION IS THAT IRS
PLOLLAZA ANDTHE BUILS SES
COLUMNS SUPPORTING THEG THSLAB E
ITSELF.
THOSE TH COMBINEWOSE  COULD BRI.
>> IT SEEMS LIKERE WERE AT
F WARNING SIGNTHERE OVER THERS
THERE ARE LIKELY RE,T SORTN THEA
OF IY NEED TO
ER?
>> WELL,F ALL, OBVIO THEY IS E
BO ANYNS THAT
THLL.AT THE TIME O
>> IT'S JUST SO AWFUL TO THINK
ABESPOS THAT
ARE JUST WAITI, WAITAND
WAITING.
THTOSURFSIDE HAS
REQUTE BOVER THEGEF 30 AND MOREN
IN TO RI
THIS 40-YEAR BUILDING
RECERTIFICATION PROGRAM.
WH DTHINK ABOUTHAT?
>> I THINK IT'D EA.
I THINK ONE OF THE MAI
HESLS A  ISSUED IN 2018, THERE
ISSUES CONINE QUALITY OF OF REMN
S BEING DONEAT UNTIL A FEW
THE ACTUAL COLPSUSLATE.
>> I THINK THIS HASO MADE
INU LOOK APLE KIND OF THE IN
FORWARD, SHOULD ALL BUILDINGS BE
INSPECTED WELL BEFORE THE
40EAMARK?
E ADJACENTO
THEY'RE EC INTRUSION
FROMEY THETHAT TENDS TO ATTACK S
AND ALL E THINGSD
HAVE